lisa is in minneapolis welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Lisa thank you so much
how are you today
better than I deserve what's up when you
say that okay so I just started
listening to you show a couple months
ago or like limit say like two months
ago my boyfriend and I are getting
pretty serious and we're planning to get
married we haven't gotten an engagement
set yet but um he turned out he's two
hundred and eighty thousand dollars in
debt with student loans Wow doctor and
yeah he's a doctor and he's a
chiropractor and he's not actually
practicing chiropractic where we live
why and it it really just doesn't make
sense for him like unless you own your
own practice and want to have that be
your lifestyle and build a couple for
several years working for someone else
the max are going to get is like 60 or
70 a year and he makes more money now
doing remodeling as a project manager
he's really skillful and he does
woodworking on the side mm-hmm yeah you
spent two hundred eighty thousand
dollars for nothing honestly I think
it's really amazing the education he did
but as far as like economically like
yeah it was stupid I I think he actually
feels like it's stupid now too and he
started school and he was just nineteen
he was really bright and he comes from
generational poverty and had no one to
advise him other lives and that's the
other issue is I wouldn't even wanna
seem like now um he makes 80 80 to 90
depending on how many hours he does
whatever you of this student loan debt
what is his view he he feels totally
crushed by it I've been kind of
breathing counting his neck about it the
last couple of months to deal with it
and he's finally starting to take it
seriously he's doing income base for a
payment but it's still gaining interest
and I'm not willing to be 50 like 56
years old when it gets so cold forgiven
and we get banged with us mm-hmm with
the tax bill so I don't think I'm not
doing that
what are you making you I make twenty
two thousand a year I work in like a
Social Work type job and I'm
I'm inactive steps right now of
interviewing at brokerage houses and
getting my real estate license okay I
don't want to do this anymore it's
bringing me out so what's your question
so well my question is we were looking
at buying this I guess it just sounds
ridiculous now that I'm saying it out
loud but we were we've always wanted to
buy rental properties and filled up like
landlording and maybe do some flipping
because we both be skillful in that I
think but we're looking at buying a
triplex in the area for about 300,000
and I I'm bringing like in our potential
marriage I'd be bringing about $100,000
to the marriage I have never had any
debt hundred dollars you guys know it's
it's in my Roth so it's not liquid cash
and I don't want to touch it too old um
well no I would not tell you to buy
investment real estate with Dan to start
with and I certainly wouldn't tell you
to buy investment real estate in the
disastrous mess that you're marrying in
yeah
so you guys have you know you have great
not downing that he's only great if he
commits to cleaning this up yeah he's
ready I just think he we both are kind
of like oh my gosh honey like where do
we even start like yeah I mean $50,000 a
year for five years and you're done I
feel like we can do that and they just
doesn't believe it's like possible and
I'm trying to get him to read this book
that you have well let me tell you the
number one cause of divorce in North
America today's money fight some money
stress it's my number one hot button too
and I'm already freaking out about it
because we're not in game if you guys
cannot get on the same page in lockstep
on this subject as big a mess as he's
got that should be a deal killer for you
totally and he's he's sitting down with
me on Saturday morning for three hours
to start hammering out a budget perfect
then you're fine you know but all the
data tells us on marriages that if you
can agree on four things prior to being
married if you agree on religion money
kids and in-laws on how to deal with
them then you actually if you can if you
can
those four categories you have a very
high statistical probability of a
successful marriage even if there's a
ridiculous mess like he's got you'll
just fight through it together it's just
a battle you take on together you can
you can fight through all kinds of stuff
when you do it together
and but if he's just like oh I'm
hopeless and I'm a victim and I'm gonna
wait 20 years to get out of this and you
you got a hole burning in the side of
your brain over this this is not going
to bode well for your relationship so
you've got to be on the same team you've
got to be pointing at the same target
with the money and my view of that would
be that you attack this debt with an
absolute vengeance and good lord no you
don't need to be buying anything right
now